hello everybody my name is markiplier
and on today's show we talk about 4000
subscribers the end of the world
brand new reaction compilation 4000
subscribers that's incredible guys you
have done an amazing job of helping me
get to this point I mean I never thought
that we could hear this fast I mean just
two months ago a little over two months
ago we started up the new channel after
the first one got thrown under the bus
by Adsense so thank you guys so much for
getting me to this point but we're not
stopping yet 4000 isn't even close to my
main goal my main goal is 100,000
subscribers in a year and with you
guys's help I think I'm going to make it
there now another thing that I want to
talk about is that my live streams have
sadly come to an end for now
I won't be doing any more of my
scheduled live streams the Monday
through Thursday 4 to 7 live streams
anymore but I will be doing 24-hour live
streams in the future I will be doing
charity streams in the future and I will
be doing special occasion live streams
in the future so it is not the end of
the world for live streams it is not the
end of me doing live streams just I have
school and I have to get a part-time job
so obviously it's going to take a bit of
time so thank you all for bearing with
me and I hope you enjoyed the live
streams for what they were it'll I only
did it for a few weeks but hopefully you
liked it at that point my live streams
will probably be coming back at some
point after school has ended or if I
figure out that I have some free time
this semester then I'll be able to
figure out when I'm going to do live
streams so thank you for bearing with me
in that the next thing I want to talk
about is I have a special surprise for
you guys
a brand new reaction compilation I
finally found the time to work on this
son of a [ __ ] and like I told you guys
before it takes hours and hours just to
add the itty-bitty subtitles in to add
the captions on the monsters to add all
those things like that if you guys want
to help the channel grow then click this
link that'll take you straight to the
reaction compilation the brand-new one
that features footage from a free
monsters and share it with your friends
time to cheer whatever it takes just get
them to watch the video
but seriously share it on Facebook share
with your friends share it with anyone
who happens to like Let's Plays share it
on forums that's what's going to help me
grow I can only do so much I can make
the videos but I depend on you guys to
help me grow and now I've made a point
of not asking at the end of every video
but I do think that special occasions
like me making an actual compilation
video like this where it compiles all
the best moments of me and my videos
that'll help get more attention because
it helped people understand what my
channel is all about and how I play my
games and how I do commentary so if you
guys can help me out by sharing that
would be greatly beneficial to my
channel so please click on the link
watch the video enjoy it do whatever you
want to it and if you feel like it
please share it with your friends so
thank you for that wow that's all the
time I have for this village thank you
all so much for watching
I do appreciate each and every one of
you I can't believe we got to 4000
subscribers so quickly so thank you
again for everything you've done for me
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye